legendary streamer from canada pulling  the tactics  look at that and now there is there are  two passports on the board the bishop  should not be able to handle that a  simple king up kingapony 5  is going to disconnect the bishop from  the pawn this is going to be over uh  very soon well done to eric i mean  you know he's clearly showing that uh  streaming chess is still  uh a way to keep you sharp and uh  very much in  good form well he  he needs that because he didn't have the  best first day  that's right i mean this is obviously  resignable um  so  let me just give the scores um  let me i should probably just wait for  this one to finish i should be i should  show some decency here  yeah i think yeah eric just announced  his  dirty intention of just walking across  and just sack